d'autres gars sont coincés avec
toutes les vacances d'une famille et nous n'avons personne que nous
ne sommes pas censés laisser, ils nous laissent
ici comme des ordures,
ils ne se soucieraient même pas que les îles
de Northland elles-mêmes soient
temporairement interdites d'
accord
oh  merde j'ai regardé l'argent qu'est-ce que
tu fais Oh quelle situation d'urgence
s'il te plaît tiens tes cheveux qu'est-ce qui se passe
quand mon père tue ma soeur ha nous allons mourir et
si nous sommes deuxièmes nous ne le savons même
pas ce n'est pas à propos de toi  agents
vous avez-vous expérimenté il aimait
autant rien sur votre corps même pas 18 ans
mais vous devez sortir d'ici
peu importe comment
chacun pour soi
se passe